[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american
supernatural drama film called nine days
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is set in a dystopian world
where unborn souls are tested for nine
days if the souls pass the tests they
are given the chance to live in the real
world however the ones that do not pass
the tests perish forever the ones that
eventually get to live in the real world
have no memory of this interview either
a man named will who lives in an
isolated house in the middle of an
unknown desert is the arbiter of souls
will judges souls and decides which ones
get to inhabit the bodies of living
beings he interviews souls for a chance
to be born in the real world
not all candidates make the cut but will
gives them each an experience of their
choosing before their existence is
erased forever the only eternal company
will has is a man named kaio a
supervisor who makes sure will selects
the best candidate and assists him with
the process before becoming an evaluator
for unborn souls will previously lived
as a normal human but kyo has never
gotten to live as a living being will
spends most of his time watching and
taking notes on a multitude of
old-fashioned television screens each of
which displays the life of a different
individual that will previously selected
among all the souls he has chosen a 28
year old violin prodigy named amanda is
his favorite one day while on her way to
a concerto amanda drives very fast on
the highway and crashes into an overpass
resulting in her death
will is devastated by her death and
watches old videos of hers for comfort
however will doesn't get much time to
mourn amanda's death and the following
day new candidates begin arriving to
interview for the vacancy amanda left
behind the candidates include kane ann
alexander mike and others the interview
lasts for nine days during which will
would test their personalities and
character he asks the candidates simple
questions about life and has them take
notes on what they like or dislike about
the lives of others who were chosen on
the first day will briefs the candidates
about the whole process before starting
the interview some candidates are more
curious than others kane asks well the
difference between being here and being
alive when will reveals that any feeling
sensation or emotion is much less
intense here than in real life cain asks
him how he is sure about that and will
is forced to admit that he has the
experience of living as a person curious
kane asks what will achieved as a living
person but will shuts him down saying he
can't divulge any more personal details
everyone answers the question in their
own way after finishing the interviews
will and kyo get on with their daily
tasks later that evening the last
candidate emma shows up late for the
interview will is annoyed by emma's
tardiness but kaio convinces him to let
her give the interview emma is just as
inquisitive as kane and she asks if kyo
is will's boss but kyle quickly corrects
her and jokes that if he was he would
never hire will emma also learns that
kaio has never been alive will then asks
her the same moral dilemma question but
emma refuses to answer because in both
instances her son dies will tells her
that she must answer the question
because that's how the question is
supposed to be emma puts forth her own
question and asks if that's how the
question is or that's how cruel the
world is emma and will both refuse to
answer each other's question and the
interview comes to an end the next day
will gives the selected candidates a
tour of the house including the control
room from which will and kyle keep an
eye on the previously selected
candidates he gives the candidate a task
to observe people on the tv and make
notes on a living being of their choice
while observing a living being we'll
notice his mic drawing on his notebook
when will asks to see it mike is
initially hesitant but eventually allows
will to see his art it is a beautiful
sketch of a beach
later will goes through each of their
notebooks and assesses them all of them
have written about one specific moment
of their choice except emma who has
written about a little bit of everything
he then individually returns their
notebook back in person will advises
emma that she could be more selective
however emma can never be bound by
anyone she asks him if the candidates he
selected remember him
will answers in a negative but he also
mentions amanda momentarily remembering
him in her childhood meanwhile kane asks
well if there's any area in which he
should work on however will tells him
not to think that way will says he
doesn't want kane to do what will thinks
is right he wants cain to do what he
deep down feels is right not satisfied
by his response kane points out how will
is going to judge him in the end anyway
and asks will to tell him the rules so
he can play the game better as expected
will doesn't reveal the rules and he
gives the candidates new assignments he
asks the candidates to pick a moment
they didn't like from what they saw on
the screen after examining their answers
will decides to eliminate mike a tearful
mike asks what he did wrong but will
gives him his same standard answer will
tries to comfort him and commends him
for living every second there with
intensity and honesty before asking him
to choose a moment that he wants to
experience from what he saw on the tv
later that night emma overhears will and
caillou working in the middle of the
night after learning that they are
working to give mike a special farewell
emma offers to help while working
caillou shares that if given a chance he
would love to yell like tarzan from the
top of a mountain emma then asks will
which moment he would choose but an
irritated will doesn't have time for her
questions and tells her to just focus on
the work after finishing the work
caillou tells emma that will is the only
interviewer who gives his candidates a
chance to experience a real world moment
he also reveals that when will was alive
he was too good kind and sensitive will
was talented but struggled to fit into a
world that was different from him he had
so much love in him but no one to give
it to
will was a simp the next day will checks
the assignment of the remaining
candidates kane tells him about the kid
named rick who is a frequent target of
bullies he continues that he doesn't
like the fact that rick doesn't fight
back more than the fact that other
children bully rick kane says that if he
was in rick's place he would hit the
bully's back when will questions him if
he justifies violence kane replies that
self-defense is justice when it is
emma's turn she describes a guy that
hates himself she says that the guy
thinks he is a failure and everything he
does is worthless and shameful emma says
she empathizes with the guy for having
gone through so much to the point that
he just wants to feel nothing anymore
she further adds that the numbness may
make him feel safe but it is also
poisoning what's left of him she says
that deep inside the man he knows it too
will realizes that emma is describing
him but stops short of acknowledging it
he says that the man she is describing
sounds irreparable emma quickly responds
that the man thinks he is irreparable
but she believes that there's still
something left inside of him will then
excuses himself to bid mike goodbye with
the help of caillou emma follows him to
a secret room where will gives the
candidates their final experience before
they disappear forever emma watches in
astonishment as mike experiences the
beach well created for him well then
sits with a tearful mike as he is lost
forever
afterwards an emotional will returns to
the tv room and sits with emma he tells
her that when he was alive he used to be
a part of a theater group in high school
he reveals he didn't have any friends
and he once gave a theater performance
that made him feel alive but he never
pursued his passion after that in
between taking interviews will continues
to watch old videos of amanda to figure
out how she crashed her car will
eventually discovers that amanda
deliberately crashed her car and
committed suicide will is shocked by the
revelation and blames himself for
sending amanda into the cruel world
unprepared as a result will starts
fearing a similar fate for a
kind-hearted emma he gives her tough
scenarios but she always chooses
kindness and love during the course of
the interview maria falls in love with
will she writes him a letter and
expresses her love however will turns
her down and eliminates her after
experiencing her final moment maria
breaks into tears and pleads with will
to give their love a chance but will
heartlessly watches her disappear into
the air all of this leads to will and
caillou getting into an argument caillou
accuses well of shutting himself off and
confronts him about his intentions to
eliminate a good candidate like emma
will argues that he can't keep sending
flowers to the real world while other
interviewers send pigs that eat them
they eventually cool down and again
start discussing amanda will admits that
just like him amanda must have felt
immense pain that no one could see with
their eyes will ultimately decides to
burn all of amanda's tapes and move on
moreover over the course of the next few
days most of the candidates are
dismissed for various reasons such as
self-consciousness and lack of respect
for suffering the candidates are
eventually narrowed down to two emma and
kane on the ninth day emma finally meets
kane they both are contrasting in
character emma is carefree kind and sees
the best in people kane is more
pessimistic recognizing the evil in the
world and showing resolve to fight back
against it over dinner the two get to
know each other will makes the two of
them sit in a room together and asks
them to tell each other why they
shouldn't be alive this naturally makes
emma uncomfortable and she walks out
later despite kyo recommending that will
pick emma will chooses kane to be born
will offers emma a last experience and
she writes something down on a piece of
paper however emma writes something
which will can't seem to do will asks
her to choose something else but she
declines a last experience as emma
prepares to leave will sees kane off to
the real world emma asks to see will one
last time but he decides not to see her
off kyle offers to be with her in her
last moments but she declines and opts
to walk across the desert until she
disappears
after emma leaves will finds a note from
her where she thanks him for everything
she expresses regret for all the things
he went through because of which he
doesn't allow himself to feel alive she
tells him that she has written all the
beautiful memories she made in the last
nine days all over the house
she asks him to not take those moments
for granted before signing off puzzled
will looks around and finds them written
all over the house those moments are a
day at the beach kyo yelling off a cliff
laughing with cane a bicycle ride and
many others will suddenly realizes that
those were indeed happy moments feeling
regret he runs out after emma he
eventually catches up to her and
passionately recites selections from
walt whitman's song of myself thanking
her for daring him to allow himself to
breathe
this movie gives us fresh perspective on
life it teaches us that there might be
lots of terrible things happening in our
life which will make us doubt if it's
worth living for but if we appreciate
those little happy moments throughout
our life we will realize that it is
worth living for subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching